today on our show we're going to Netflix
yeah that's right man bust your nut
flicks for Netflix
as weed - thank you as we talk about
Netflix projects in the pipeline coming
soon which both sound sexier than we
meant it
today on fat man on back and of all
[Music]
and on Batman we will come to fat man on
Batman Kevin Smith I'm mark Barnard
mark you got a subscription to this new
thing Netflix they send you DVDs to your
house you could stick them in the mail
whenever you want I do I'm a really big
fan of that because you get like one CD
or one DVD like every three days if you
can burn through them if you don't have
to return them fast so they don't give a
[ __ ] saves me a trip to the video store
you know it's changing my life
absolutely used to say and now oh my god
netflix owns us all ladies and gentlemen
and that's because they out constantly
put [ __ ] up there that we like to watch
and if they put up something you don't
like to watch [ __ ] it wait two minutes
we're gonna put up something you will
like to watch there's 8,000 other things
on there that you like to watch also and
there's [ __ ] you never heard of that you
might wind up liking to watch I fell
down a rabbit hole today and I've
watched this John Slattery movie God's
pocket heard of it didn't see it he'll
Seymour Hoffman Jonathan's world like an
impressive cast Christina Hendricks is
[ __ ] good [ __ ] now we found it because I
was looking for owning Mahoney another
Philip Seymour Hoffman flick that wasn't
anyone any service not just watch on
YouTube and not even legally I have
watch it no dice but in any event
Netflix is that [ __ ] it's a never
ending put plethora of goodness Netflix
is a company I can get behind like Apple
mmm my [ __ ] Marvel a [ __ ] DC Hogan
company that makes these akf let admit
these are products that like if I could
swear by because I use them like [ __ ]
daily and they make your life better
bang so this boards Netflix jpgs
bowlinator Netflix xlm marijuana if
we're going alphabetically marijuana and
that's why I put them together chill so
what's going on in the world of Netflix
they are any announcing [ __ ] mood oh
they're not canceling anymore [ __ ]
so far nothing's been blogged pulled but
let's to recap they've got rid of sense
eight but then they'll okay we're going
to let them finish with this Brazil so
bang yes they got rid of to get down
they got rid of
I'm enough whatever the [ __ ] it's not
coming back you don't care but the ones
that are coming this is the news
Umbrella Academy
that's the Gerard Way comic book Gabriel
ba that the nervous yeah I'm such a
writer snob I always look like [ __ ]
writer but you're right the book has
incredible look to its name Gabriel ba
key and Fabio moon are twins really from
Brazil really yeah mark with the inside
info adorable gentleman also Umbrella
Academy is all sorts of adorable if you
don't know this book it's kind of like
Gerard ways version of the x-men by way
of well the brilliance of true hard way
yeah that's a good old-fashioned absence
joke stuff um it is uh smart very smart
such a good idea this is like you know
you got they got a Marvel Universe and
stuff like that but is like having your
own version of the x-men absolutely and
it's got the [ __ ] cachet of like
being a head comic is darkhorse book yep
won awards and Eisner award-winning
comics and it's got been written by a
dude that's has a following or two yeah
a couple people know this Casas work but
yes the Netflix handed out a 10 episode
straight to series order live-action and
I have a dream this message
that's smart that is smart this very
smart person because they're doing very
well for themselves in the superhero
game like their Marvel Universe stuff is
gang like killing a crashing servers
good for them why not give versatile and
I got the defenders coming up in a
minute very totally that's all yes that
one it happened is that is a superhero
thing that we forgot to put on that
little calendar if she's coming down the
pike it's true defender defenders in our
in August okay so that's [ __ ] I'm all
on board yes
drug when it dried ways co-executive
producing it fella named Steve Blackman
who was on Fargo and Netflix's altered
carbon will be the showrunner and will
executive produce alongside Mike
Richardson from Dark Horse and Keith
Colburn from Dark Horse jord way
co-executive producer hot damn
it's pretty damn sweet man pilot script
was adapted from the comic book series
by Jeremy Slater he wrote The Exorcist
series yeah TV Sean ha because that's
happening or is that done
I'm not going to so here it was real
I heard is good I mean they did some
dark [ __ ] that I would not have expected
him to do watch
I saw the pilot and it [ __ ] up and it
connected
she's like Reagan's kid or a grown-up or
some associated because smartly like
don't abandon an audience remember the
original thing like if there's a Wayne I
hide in why not maybe it doesn't cost
you anything
do it go check it out people in the
audience oh I got canceled three years
ago six yeah I've got a second season
will be this codes coming back yeah so I
should get on board this exorcist train
you can give it a shot the devil sells
mmm devil made and devil he intrigues me
all right so that's happened on Netflix
what else is happening on that may I say
I don't want to watch the Umbrella
Academy I'm one of those [ __ ] people
what else can I look at may have you
heard of a television program on your
streaming services bed was over age
exchange of things oh yes they finally
drop some news they drop some news they
finally gave us a gate for the second
season
duffer brothers duffer bros are back in
it October 27 is the date for the second
season of it that's good here is the
season 2 plot description according to
Netflix it's 1984 and the citizens of
Hawkins Indiana are still reeling from
the horrors of the demo Gordon and the
secrets of Hawkins lab will Byers has
been rescued from the upside down but a
bigger sinister entity still threatens
those who survived mmm and if you saw
the poster the sky is on fire fYI shits
coming down that's going to make well
you can't make money
I couldn't have all the eyeballs that is
going to that is going to crash the
[ __ ] servers October through November
is going to be shut down in America as
everyone watches stranger things season
to season do it did and the last thing
that crashed the servers on Netflix Luke
Cage
iron fist afib nose looking cage crash
servers but iron fist that was
ridiculous amount of beauty air like
that's the most watched one we've ever
and but yeah I think it was they were
not prepared for the desire from the
cage and the second season premiere of
Luke Cage smell the segue smell the
segue will be directed by let me guess
who could it be
like guna baseball cap gotta be Kevin
Smith
this job calls for the eye the sensitive
eye of an outsider like myself it is not
it turns out a white dude in a baseball
cap thank the Lord
it is an Asian lady who could wear a
baseball cap if she wanted to it is not
just any Asian lady it is Lucy Liu
oh really Lucy [ __ ] she's
directed episodes of Elementary yeah
yeah that's where she's like a fat her
teeth oh right on that's kind of cool
yeah Mary that's very cool Martha Marvel
why not get her me a little bit extra
press - yeah like not only do you have a
director business director people know
and they could allow you're an actress
and you can you doin a lot of things
it's a good it's if I know how to fellow
newspaper inches he understand for
ecology does anymore
we did it the other times did you call
them inches had to figure out how many
[ __ ] words are in an inch
how many forty all right yeah [ __ ]
learn some [ __ ] on this show I'm
learning some [ __ ] that will aid you
incredibly well if you travel back to
1977 to get a job at the Daily News
right otherwise useless if you're
watching all the President's Men
beautiful information right here and if
you're navigating the 21st century you
don't need to know what college is on uh
Lucy Liu directing Luke Cage that's cool
what a thrill to collaborate with Marvel
Netflix she says in a statement to
industry Titans who paint our world with
inspiring stories and beguiling
characters is such an honor to work with
such a passionate and fearless team set
her publicity squad I'm gonna say great
it is we get it I'll buy the job yeah
heavens and a Jeph Loeb love Jeff oh
he's excited to have you on board
can I do a quick [ __ ] Jeph Loeb knob
polished
bio me Jeff Loeb was the guy that made
me want to write comic books because he
a lot of people like Kevin Smith was the
first one from Hollywood or from movies
to come over and do comics that is
Peyton Lee untrue
Sam Hamm who wrote the Batman script in
series called blind justice for
detective but started in like 600 or
something I forget which issue but more
importantly Jeph Loeb wrote challengers
of the unknown with tendons Eldridge for
DC
and I remember when that came out like
there was no internet so you couldn't
like I'm going to look him up but I knew
that he had written both Teen Wolf and
commando so there he was writing a comic
book and I was like wow man you could do
that you can work in the movies and you
could write a comic walk between worlds
I'll let you do that he was the first
one to walk between worlds so when I got
my chance and stuff like that I said I
would kill or die to write one of these
comics amount of bright and daredevil
line of bright and green out but only
because I knew because he someone always
nothing original in this world you got
to see it before you can be it and so I
saw him I seed him be it I feed him and
I beat him what the fun I lost the
analogy but we got in that ball bought
it by birth
speaking of challenging an unknown why
is that not a TV show right I mean shut
up [ __ ] this is our problem what a good
idea that loud and we don't see
ourselves going to talk to people
no Jeff John's we could literally go in
and be like me and Mark want to go out
with Challenger they all know that cool
everybody forget me said back it's just
one but still let it go you're over
sharing or what we do is have a good
idea movie pilot can now just say it's
happening it's like just our friends at
movie pile just write up that we're
already doing it and then Marvel I mean
DC and more buzz we're like oh we're
doing this we're doing a good idea and
quotes don't attribute the quote to
anybody yep that's that's just to say
exactly unnamed sir that is a good idea
that challenge of the unknown would be
an excellent [ __ ] TV series yeah and
Wow and not even like Netflix like you
do that on [ __ ] TV absolutely it's no
reason that could be an NBC show just
weekly [ __ ] adventure like rocky a
girl oh forget it always sorry guys is
that all our Netflix news that is all of
it it looks it means my friend there it
is glow is happening right now if you
watch it yet I haven't heard an amazing
I keep hearing great things about it
Andrew off camera just gave it one of
these yeah I'm like cool either he's
going I love [ __ ] or he's saying
glow rocks or all he's doing is a prompt
could be both one is not truth was close
amazing it's perfect it 2050 together
yeah every time he makes a point you
think anybody tries to do that remember
that game dude did your finger in you
get to them punch I think he's just
given himself a ok like every now and
again he needs a little like yeah I'm
great
that's the game isn't getting ball here
the game is I don't forget what movie
were doing the Sun but it's about I
think Degrassi it's about making people
like you just did you look so the alt so
if you look I could punch you the only
way I don't get to punch you is if you
look yes and you can kind of treat the
circle so what a great game of it I mean
but yeah it's all it's all about this is
just like let me tell you something you
know like that word did you see that or
oh my god this might you know been seen
as give a look Daniel I got there it is
that's our pitch for the Netflix series
challenges in the unknown hey I can be
on TV challenges absolutely we can it is
it's not ours but you know what
it'll happen because it's a property and
it can be done and can be episodic and
then in two years somebody will say on
Twitter hey somebody was listening to
you guys challenges is happening you
should get money and we'll say I know
and it will give up another amazing idea
we could ever get money for gone like
you know what they should do with their
characters you should make a show out of
that yeah I know they're doing for the
game is not just being an agent kind of
then we missed they're calling a parent
are we trying to be creative we would
10% or no I'm saying we should you got
build up with talented people yeah and
all you got to do schmooze and [ __ ] like
that and getting people spaces on your
clients that hey yo you [ __ ] figure
talking it is mark Mardon but probably a
[ __ ] list should be this guy [ __ ]
that is a doggy let's talk about 10
percent of rain 99% of this show is over
we have 1% left you look you look I
would go how much much about myself
it gotta be fast but that's the thing
you played a game so often because that
you're ready like you have to live on a
stay in a state of cat-like readiness
expecting everyone around you to be
doing this because then you can [ __ ]
again oh it sounds like a game if people
just want to punch everybody okay good
it's not so much it's like a drinking
game just [ __ ] drink it is a game to
get you a drink or just punch
don't combine those why my planet games
beat me oh now you can punch me hugging
you here you connect your heart you do
see you were ready I trained you that
was my [ __ ] Mickey moment or my rocky
moment if we're doing create nice or I'm
we went to Shambhala and I figured it
all [ __ ] out and I so it's your
shadow moment no it's your doctor shows
realize your Doctor Strange moment I
caught it extremes there for a second
[ __ ] yes um pain yeah [ __ ] the shadow
that could work now it's I mean it's
such a it's such a pulp concept I don't
make it period it can't be period we've
seen what it looks like period yes that
could've been a cool movie because I saw
that a miracle
but yeah you just looked like his
brother as the shadows yeah like here's
how you know he's the shadow he's got a
bigger nose and it looks like billy-o
but can we make a show that's handsome
and grotesque it could be you know what
that could be a series as well somebody
should be doing in the shadow of the
serious why not that makes more sense to
say rainy wasn't little to share I think
he still has the rights to it
hope he doesn't seriously there's a guy
those that do TV show them alright
alright the Pope all right yes there it
is man for fat man on Batman I've been
Kevin Smith and I've been more preneur
come back next time we'll talk about
other people's work that's not our own
same bat-time same bat-channel spot cast
icon warm YouTube Garcons let's go
you
[Music]